ALLEN LO: All right.
Well, thank you.
Welcome, all of you who are
here in the room and those
of you who are joining
us on live stream.
This is part of
AAPI Heritage Month.
AGN is happy to host today's
panel called AAPI in the Public
Eye, White House Commissioners
on Civic Engagement.
So welcome to all of you here.
We'll have some time at
the end for questions.
So think of your questions
now, giving you a fair warning.
I'll basically ask some
questions of the panel
as we go along here.
But we'll make sure to have
questions here at the end.
I'm Allen Lo.
I'm in the legal
department here at Google.
Let me introduce the
panelists for you.
Sitting immediately to my
left is Lorna May Ho Randlett.
She currently serves on
the commission for WHIAAPI,
which is the White House
Initiative on Asian American
Pacific and Pacific Islanders.
She previously was a
communications specialist
and reach and relevance
external relations manager
at McKinsey, where she
represented McKinsey's
global semiconductor practice.
But more recently, she founded
a nonprofit organization
called the Leaders
Forum that helps,
in particular,
Asian leaders make
the transition from government
into private practice and vice
versa.
So maybe Lorna can talk
about that some more
during the panel.
Sitting next to
her is Bill Imada.
Bill serves also on the
commission, the WHIAAPI
commission.
He's the founder, chairman,
and chief connectivity officer
for IW Group.
You have to tell us
what that means as well.
IW Group is a minority-owned
and operated advertising,
marketing, and communications
agency focusing on the growing
multicultural markets.
Sitting next to Bill
is Kathy Ko Chin.
She's a former
commissioner of WHIAAPI.
So we've got the two current
commissioners sitting closest
to me, and we've put
the former commissioners
a little further away.
She currently serves as a
president and CEO of the Asian
and Pacific Islander
American Health
Forum, which is a position
she's held since 2010.
And before that, she has
been in a number of positions
in the health care space.
She was the program director
for the Community Clinics
Initiative, which is a
joint project of Tides
and the California Endowment.
And then sitting next to
Kathy is Dr. Tung Van Nguyen.
He was a former chairperson
of the commission,
of the WHIAAPI commission.
He's a professor of medicine
at UC San Francisco, where
he provides medical care to
a diverse patient population
and teaches clinicians.
And so you've got,
basically, folks here
who've been on the commission,
who are on the commission.
And so we should just
actually jump into that.
So let's talk about
WHIAAPI, especially
for those who may not
be familiar with it.
What is WHIAAPI?
And what does it do?
I don't know.
Who wants to take that one?
KATHY KO CHIN: Former chair.
Former chair.
TUNG NGUYEN: Yeah,
there's a lot--
can you hear?
ALLEN LO: Yeah.
TUNG NGUYEN: There's a
lot to say about WHIAAPI.
But most importantly, it is a--
obviously, is in
the White House.
And it is responsible
for, basically,
engaging the Asian-American
Pacific Islander community
and also making sure that issues
related to the AAPI communities
are represented and addressed
by the federal government.
Historically, it was created
under President Clinton,
and has been renewed under
every president since.
We were appointed
by President Obama.
That's the short history.
Maybe there are a
couple other things
you might want to mention.
LORNA RANDLETT: No,
I think that's good.
Yeah, sorry.
Go ahead.
KATHY KO CHIN: Well, I think
the really wonderful thing
about serving on the
commission is that they--
there are 20
commissioners, or it
can be authorized for
up to 20 commissioners.
And we came from all
over the country.
And each person
represented a variety
of either their geography, their
ethnicity, the area of the work
that they did, but
collectively really were
the eyes and the ears
of the White House
into the community to make sure
that we could understand what
communities were facing
and then bring that back
to the White House.
ALLEN LO: Great.
And so Kathy and
Tung, you guys decided
after Trump was elected to
step down from the commission.
Can you talk about
your decision,
why you made that decision, how
you arrived at that decision?
And then for, I guess, Bill
and Lorna, you decided to stay.
So maybe, Bill and
Lorna, you can talk
about why you decided to stay.
KATHY KO CHIN: Should I go first
and then I'll give it to you?
So in my job, the Asian and
Pacific Islander American
Health Forum, we are
the nation's advocates
for Asian-Americans,
native Hawaiians,
and Pacific Islanders on health.
And so our job is to actually
hold government accountable.
Our job is to push on
the federal government
to make sure that
health services are
as accessible as possible.
And I really felt
that it was going
to be more advantageous
for our work
to be able to have a
little bit more separation
between the administration and
the work that we had to do.
TUNG NGUYEN: I joined
the commission mainly
because I wanted to
help our community.
And I felt that, at that
point, I wasn't able to.
I think that there
are reasons to stay
and there are reasons to go.
But I think, on the
balance, it felt
like I wasn't going to be
able to do enough to do that.
And also, a large number
of our commissioners
also wanted to leave.
And I wanted to make sure that
I could support them as well.
But having said that, I really--
one of the cool things about
serving in the commission
is the diverse points of
view and diverse approaches
to solving problems.
So it was totally
understandable that some of us
thought that we would solve
the problems by leaving
and some of us would solve
the problems by staying.
And I think, in a way, that's
what's really important,
is that even when we
disagree on the approach,
we actually need
different approaches.
LORNA RANDLETT: So I am so
grateful that Tung gave me
that very kind lead-in into
why some of us decided to stay.
I personally decided
to stay because I
felt like I was appointed for--
by a president for a term.
And I thought it was important
to honor that term, which
is until the end of September.
In addition to that, I
also felt that our chair--
not our chair, but our chair
within the administration, who
is the Surgeon General, decided
that he was going to stay on.
And I felt that, given
the fact that we had staff
as well at the White House,
that it was important
that there was some leadership
within the commissioners
to stay, to be able to try
to impact the process even
within the new administration
on behalf of AAPIs
as best as we possibly could.
BILL IMADA: So for me, when
President Trump was elected,
it was really difficult
to have that conversation.
And I have to speak as a
private citizen and not
as a commissioner.
So I wanted to just put
that out there right away.
I was working on a fraud case.
There was a young
Asian-American woman
in Los Angeles who was scammed.
And the federal
government was pursuing
a case against the scammer.
And because that case was
pending, if all of us resigned,
then this woman would not have
had counsel going forward.
So we had just
started the effort
to look into the scammer.
We were making some headway.
This person was really
traumatized by being scammed.
She lost her identity.
She lost her ability
to do business.
She was getting all
sorts of charges
all around the world
to her credit card.
And I said, I think
I have to stay.
We're focusing on bullying.
Bullying is a terrible
problem in our community.
And WHIAAPI has done
so much to make sure
that Asian-Americans and Pacific
Islanders are not bullied,
and people of different
religious beliefs,
like Muslims, that I did not
think that we should leave
without making sure
that we at least try
to have a proper hand-off
on that bullying discussion.
And then we also had
staff, as Lorna said.
We had a number of people
that were career staff.
And if the entire
commission resigned,
then there would be no
reason to have a staff.
And so I felt some
obligation to stay in hope
that, when the new
administration came
on board, that we would
be able to at least save
some of the great work that
we had completed in WHIAAPI,
including the anti-bullying
work, including
our work around DACA,
the Affordable Care Act,
as well as all the
things that we were doing
to help keep government
accessible for Asian-Americans
and Pacific Islanders.
ALLEN LO: So with
the resignations,
there are how many commissioners
now that are still there?
Is it four?
There's four commissioners--
LORNA RANDLETT: Four of us.
ALLEN LO: --out of the 20?
LORNA RANDLETT: Correct.
ALLEN LO: So there were 16 that
resigned, and four stayed on.
Looking backwards,
what would you
say were some of the
proudest achievements
that you've accomplished over
the last couple of years?
LORNA RANDLETT: I would
have to concur with Bill.
And I guess I should
say that I have
to speak on behalf of-- as
a private citizen as well,
even though I suppose we
can talk about that work.
I think that the anti-bullying
work was really important
for us, because I think that
one of the things that we share
across cultures is looking
to the next generation
and making the path
easier or better for them.
And so focusing on
trying to make sure
that young people felt
like they were going
to be able to pursue
the American Dream
and not have these
barriers and anything
we could do in that
regard is probably
among the proudest
accomplishments.
I specifically worked on
cultivating the business
community, because I think that
when you talk about where--
frankly, a lot of Asians
have had a lot of success
that is actually recognized
by the entire country, right?
I mean, you obviously have
a South-Asian CEO, right?
Took up Microsoft,
Pepsi, whatever,
you name it, Mastercard, right?
So I thought that it
was important to bring
that conversation and
those accomplishments
into the forefront so we could
be dealing with our community
from a position of strength.
BILL IMADA: I don't want
to take the thunder away
from these two, so I'm going
to focus on one that I think
is amazing, is
part of our job is
to make sure that the
federal government is
accessible to Asian-Americans
and Pacific Islanders.
And WHIAAPI and staff pulled
together federal agencies
from all around the country, I
mean, from Alaska to Florida,
from the island areas all the
way up to Maine, to California,
and brought them together--
Department of Labor,
Department of Commerce,
Department of
Education, CIA, SBA,
I mean, all these really
important federal agencies--
and got them to sit down
together to find solutions
for Asian-Americans
and Pacific Islanders
to make sure that government
is accessible and works
for the people that they're
supposed to work for.
And so I thought that was one
of the proudest achievements
for WHIAAPI, is pulling
together all these agencies
and getting them to work
together to solve problems
in our community.
KATHY KO CHIN: One of the
areas that I had worked
on as a commissioner was DACA.
And so I appreciate, Bill,
that you raised that.
The Deferred Action
for Childhood Arrivals
is for the dreamers, right?
So the young people who
came as children, that
were undocumented.
And President Obama had
provided the DACA program.
There are a lot.
There's something
estimated like two million
DACA-eligible people in
our Asian-Pacific Islander
community.
The enrollment has
been a lot lower
than in other
communities, but I really
felt that WHIAAPI
and the commissioners
played an important role in
doing outreach and really
trying to understand
what were the barriers
and challenges in our
community, but also
how to make sure that
our communities knew
that this opportunity
was available.
TUNG NGUYEN: I
have a lot to say,
so I want to try
to make it quick.
So for number one, Affordable
Care Act and enrollment
of Asian-Americans, both in
terms of getting the act passed
and in terms of engaging.
And Kathy is too modest to
talk about her work in getting
Asian-American to sign--
Asian-American and
Pacific Islander
to sign up to get health care.
So up to two million
Asian-Americans benefited.
So we felt that was a huge
win for our community.
Disaggregated data--
so we were a big--
everyone knows that
Asian-Americans and Pacific
Islanders, on the outside,
looks like it's one group.
But on the inside,
everyone knows that there's
a lot of different groups.
And each of those groups wants
to see data about themselves.
And federal
government is probably
the only agency that's actually
going to be able to do that.
So we fought very hard to get
disaggregated data collected,
and of any time
when it is possible.
And we can talk about
how that's gone.
We had some successes.
We still have a long way to go.
Regional connections--
so not only
did we convene all
these great agencies
in Washington DC at
the national level,
we also knew that
Asian-Americans a lot of times
can't go to Washington DC.
But they needed to interact
with the federal government
where they lived.
And so we were able to create
these so-called regional
networks where we linked
Asian-Americans communities
to 6, 7, 8, 9, 10 different
federal government
agencies in their area
so that they can actually
address any local issues.
I think those are probably
the biggest thing.
I had one other
thing, which I forgot.
But I'll come back to it.
ALLEN LO: Great.
So let's pivot a little bit to--
away from WHIAAPI
specifically, and talk more
generally about Asian relations
here in the United States
today.
When we look at over the last
100 years in the United States,
the ways Asians have been
perceived and treated
has evolved over time.
And it depends on the
time and the circumstance.
So if you look
100-plus years ago,
there was the Yellow Peril and
legislation to keep Asians out.
You had World War II and
you had internment camps
and the treatment of
Japanese during World War II.
More currently, you've got the
image of the model minority
for Asians.
Tung, you mentioned
disaggregation of data.
It was, I think, 1980 where
the census started counting
Asian-Americans as a class.
And as you mentioned,
I mean, there
are many different
subclasses within this class.
But oftentimes, we're
lumped together.
And maybe-- the term sometimes
is used is we're racialized.
And given today, where we're
at today with the Trump
administration, with
various events that
have happened recently--
you have the United
Airlines incident.
You've got different--
the Airbnb--
there's been some press
about owners not wanting
to rant to Asians.
Where are we today?
How are Asians perceived today?
How are they being
racialized today?
LORNA RANDLETT: Well,
I'll tackle that question
by just saying I think it
depends on where you sit,
right?
Where you are socioeconomically,
what part of the country that
you live in on how you
would answer that question .
What I will tell you is
someone recently told me--
with a Latino Victory Fund--
a saying that he had heard that
one of his mentors told him,
which said, if you are not--
if you are not part
of the restaurant,
you are on the menu.
And that was his way
of saying regardless
of where we sit in the
country, unequivocally
the country looks at us
in one category in terms
of the federal
government and how they
fund programs and the like.
And it behooves us to really
try to, at some point,
collaborate and work
on that power together.
Because frankly, in
a lot of situations,
including when you talk about
the government in our country--
at least as it relates to
the political process--
there are two things
that really matter.
It's money, and it's votes.
And unless we're bringing
our money together,
we're bringing our
votes together--
and this is just
my perspective--
we are not going to get closer
to actually achieving the power
that I think Asian-Americans
deserve rightfully so
as an economic engine
in this country.
So that's my perspective.
BILL IMADA: I just want
to say that there's
a scholar over at
Columbia University.
Her name is Vishakha Desai.
She used to lead the Asian
Society here in the States,
in New York.
And she once said that being
labeled a model minority
makes us invisible.
And what's going to be very
important for all of you
in the audience, for
each of us is that we
need to stand up for ourselves.
And we need to be better
about speaking up,
even for someone like Allen.
If something
happens to Allen, we
want to make sure that
everyone at Google
knows how important
someone like him is.
And I have to tell
you, because we
are viewed as this
model minority that
gets along with everyone and
doesn't want to rock the boat.
We've seen 96 Asian-American
executives lose their jobs
in less than five years at
major Fortune 500 companies.
If it was a Latino
executive and this
happened at one of the
television stations, one of--
an Asian-American who
became president of NBC
lost his job in six months.
It's the first time an
Asian-American has ever
ascended to that role,
and he loses his job.
A Latina, who is a lower-level,
lower-ranking person
at the same station,
loses their job.
1,000 people wrote
letters for her.
Three people wrote letters
for Asian-Americans.
Now, going back to Airbnb, one
place where Asian-Americans
excel-- and I don't want to
perpetuate too many myths
and stereotypes, is that we
are early adopters of online,
so it just is safer for us
to criticize Airbnb when
that woman was denied housing
in Big Bear, of all places,
in Southern California.
But I do think that we have to
go beyond speaking out online.
We have to step up and
say, this is unacceptable.
And we as Asian Americans need
to be treated respectfully.
We are not perpetual foreigners.
We have a voice.
And I'm going to
stand by this person.
I'm going to stand by Allen.
I'm going to stand by other
executives in the company.
I'm going to stand
by community leaders.
Because we're a part
of this community
and we're all Americans and
we all value the same thing.
So in order for us to
get beyond some of this,
we've got to get
people to be activized
not only in communities, but in
corporations and in businesses.
KATHY KO CHIN: So you
asked the question, Allen,
about being
racialized as a group.
And I heard that you heard
from Buck Gee last week
or a couple weeks ago.
So Buck and I have a
connection that both of us
have been a former board chair
of the Angel Island Immigration
Station Foundation.
And so that was where the
Chinese Exclusion Act was
enforced in the United States.
And the Chinese Exclusion Act--
so this was adopted in 1882--
was the first racialized,
racially-focused exclusionary
law by Congress.
So really, if we think
back over the last 100,
150 years, our identity
as Asian-Americans
has always been
racialized, and in fact has
been connected to
detention, deportation, more
militarized enforcement
of all kinds.
So it's not something new to
think about being racialized.
In fact, that's been, really,
our history from excluding us
from coming into
the country and then
how we're treated once we're in
the country or even citizens.
The other thing that I
think is really important
about this tension,
I think, at least I
feel when I speak
around the country,
around this concept
of aggregation
versus disaggregation.
So the importance
of disaggregation
is because that's
the only way we're
going to be able to identify
the challenges and disparities
that our communities experience,
while at the same time exactly
what Lorna said about
aggregating our power.
Whether it's buying
power or political power,
it is really critical.
So we have to somehow
transcend our individual ethnic
identities or any challenges
that we have with each other
by specific
ethnicities, recognizing
that some folks from different
countries-- their countries
may have been at war with each
other for hundreds of years,
right?
So just because you come
to the United States,
doesn't mean all of a sudden
you can hold hands with somebody
who you've had
border issues with,
or border conflict
for hundreds of years.
But the issue around economic
power and political power
requires us to transcend that.
At the same time, when we
think of disaggregated data--
and I'll thank you, Tung,
for your compliment.
When it came time to do
enrollment for the Affordable
Care Act, we knew that, in
our community, because we're
one third limited
English proficient,
we were trying to
figure out, well,
how are we going to
best enroll people?
So at the Health Forum, we
were able to take the data--
which if you just collapsed
everybody together,
Asian-Americans actually had
the highest rates of insurance,
meaning if you just looked
at the lumped-together data,
it meant we didn't really
have an uninsurance problem.
But when we were able
to literally look
at it in this
disaggregated fashion,
Koreans actually had the highest
rates of uninsurance at 23%--
highest of anyone in
the whole country--
then 18% Bangladeshi,
17% Pakistani.
And so then we were able to
really focus our enrollment
efforts.
And then AAPIs had the
biggest enrollment rates.
And now, after four rounds,
we have the greatest coverage
of any racial minority
in the country.
But it's only because we
could really focus in on that
and understand that it was--
there are differences
by ethnicity.
TUNG NGUYEN: So I'm going to
take a slightly different tact.
So I'm going to talk a
little bit about philosophy,
little bit about history, and
a little bit about politics.
So the idea that we get
to define our own identity
is a very American idea, right?
You get to decide
who you want to be.
And whether or not
you identify yourself
as even an Asian-Americans
is up to you, right?
I mean, there are a lot of
Asians walking out there
who are saying, I'm not Asian.
And then if you choose to
identify yourself as Vietnamese
or Chinese or whatever.
But what's happening in
this country is pretty--
if you're not paying
attention, your identity's
also defined by
other people, right?
I mean, how they
treat you, right?
So if you go back to the bamboo
ceiling idea, for example,
a lot of young
people don't realize
that their identity is
defined by other people
until they rise up in the ranks.
And all of a sudden
something happens to them,
and they're like, what happened?
I thought I had total
control over my destiny,
and now I'm not, right?
Is it your name?
Is it the way you talk?
Is it the way they
expect you to act?
Right?
The thing about the history
that's happening right now
is you can't run away
from that anymore.
The way this country
is right now,
you have to be not
paying attention
to think that your identity
doesn't matter to other people.
People are being killed
because they're Asian.
There are brown Asian engineers.
I mean, people like
a lot of you just
got killed in Kansas
or in other places.
There was actually
a rash of killings.
There was a South-Asian doctor
who was killed, I think,
in Michigan.
These things are real.
It doesn't matter
what you think.
It's what other
people think as well.
So I mean, I just wanted
to at least reflect that.
But historically, that is
actually not new, right?
So that's the other
important thing to remember,
is this is not something
that happened with the Trump
administration.
If anything, the
Trump administrations
allow it to be
much more explicit.
It's always been there.
How many of you here actually
are either immigrants
or parents were immigrants?
Yeah, none of you
would be here if it
weren't for the Immigration
Naturalization Act of 1965, OK?
Back then, before that, the
number of Chinese or Asians
or whatever can come
into this country
were numbered in the hundreds.
They were a quota, OK, of how
many Chinese, for example,
could come into this country.
Hundreds.
All right?
After the act, thousands and
thousands of people came.
And it's great, right?
But we forget that.
We forget the fact that
we are Asian-Americans
or we are Chinese or Vietnamese.
And we are not here
if other people didn't
fight for us for us to be here.
And now that we're
here, we need to fight
for ourselves, but also
for other people as well.
So that's my
perspective on that.
BILL IMADA: Totally
agree with that.
LORNA RANDLETT: Tung, can
I add one quick thing?
And I'm so grateful that I saw
part of the Chinese Exclusion
Act movie that's
coming up on PBS.
So please look out for that
one when it happens at an event
that Bill had in Washington DC.
But I will tell you that,
even currently, when
you look at some
"immigration reforms," quote,
unquote that the
administration currently
is looking to put
forth, there are
pieces in it like the exclusion
of family members coming over.
To be clear, that hails back
to the Chinese Exclusion Act
when they tried to
limit women coming.
Because they understand,
right, the powers
that be who want
to hold Asians back
understand that if they limit
your family from coming,
then some people
won't have childcare
or they won't have
other ways in which
to support their families, which
then limits the effectiveness.
It may limit the choice on how
many children, for example,
someone who comes
here might decide
to have because they don't
have their parents coming
to help them with
their families, right?
So don't misunderstand that
even though you live now,
in this age, that there are
not still forces at work
that are trying to limit us as
Asian-Americans, as a people,
from thriving here and
growing our numbers.
And the reason they don't
want us to grow our numbers
is, again, as I said,
when there's more numbers,
there is more power.
BILL IMADA: I did want to
say that we should also be
better about telling our story.
Of course, we've got
a lot of disparities
in our community,
health care disparities,
economic disparities.
But we should also be a little
bit more proud about what
we have accomplished.
And not wanting to completely
perpetuate this model minority
myth, I do think that
we need to be louder
about our accomplishments.
I mean, our population
in the US is bigger
than 46 out of 50 states.
We are helping to create
and fuel brand new jobs.
If we were collectively
put on an island together,
we would be the 18th
economic power in the world.
And Turkey currently
holds that seat.
73 million Turks is only
20 million Asian-Americans.
So I do think we should
be better about telling
our story, the positive things.
But we also can't
forget where we're from,
and realize that lots of
other people are struggling.
So I want to see a little
better storytelling,
each of you telling
your own unique stories,
but also telling the
Asian-American story, that we
are contributing
to this country.
We are taxpayers.
We're building businesses.
We are an economic force.
And we're also
tipping the balance
in elections in key states
like Nevada and Virginia.
So I do think we
should be better
about telling our stories.
ALLEN LO: So let me
follow up on that.
So we should be better.
But what you're really
saying, without saying it,
is that we're not
that good at it.
We're not working together.
We're not using the
power of our voice.
Why aren't more AAPIs getting
involved in civic action?
What's our problem?
BILL IMADA: That's an entire
conversation all to itself.
TUNG NGUYEN: Well, I
think there is some--
I don't want to
stereotype us, but there
are some cultural
ideas that we shouldn't
stand up and say things.
There's some classic saying
like the nail that sticks up
gets nailed down.
Also, a lot of us
come from countries
where, if you stood
up and said something,
you'd get killed or put in jail.
I mean, my parents don't want
to talk anything about politics
ever, or because their
friends got put in jail.
So I think there are good
reasons that we don't stand up.
I think, though, this country
works on whether or not
you stand up or not.
So if you don't
stand up, then you're
not going to get
anything you need.
Or maybe not for yourself, but
maybe also for your community,
which is actually the more
important part, I think.
So I don't think we
are very good at that.
There are a lot of divisions.
Within, say, the Vietnamese
community, for example,
there are lots of
political divisions.
So even to stand up, to speak up
in that community is difficult.
And then there are divisions
within AAPIs, right?
So Chinese versus
Vietnamese, for example,
would be one idea, or Pakistani
and India, for example.
So there's a lot of
fault lines that we
need to understand how to
navigate before we can even
talk about it.
But what I think is important
is, rather than look
at our culture and
where we came from,
is what common
values do we have.
And if you look at
the common values
that I think a
lot of AAPIs have,
you will find the source
where you can find the goals
that you need to reach.
So for example, I would
say immigrants rights.
I'm kind of surprised if
you're Asian and don't
believe in immigrant rights.
Because like I said, if it
weren't for immigrant rights,
none of you would be here.
KATHY KO CHIN: Yeah,
and just to follow up
on that, 2/3 of the AAPI
community are immigrant,
and then one third are
limited English proficient.
So immigration is a
huge common issue.
The other thing, just to
cite some statistics--
so the AAPI community has the
highest rates of citizenship
naturalization of all
immigrant populations,
but we have among the lowest--
of those citizens, we have
among the lowest that vote.
So that gap.
I think, is where-- as we're
talking about civic engagement,
I think, is where
there is a lot of room
for people to get involved.
And so even if it's
not rocking the boat
or there's some cultural
barriers, at least
going to the ballot to vote is a
really, really important thing.
There was just released
this 2016 post-election
national Asian-American survey.
I think Tiffany has the link.
And so we can share
that with people
if people are interested.
And then I'm happy to have
people take a look at this one.
What is really interesting
is the interests
of communities around
education and health
care and immigration.
But the challenge
still is how to get
people to register to vote, and
then actually get out the vote.
There are also some
structural issues on that.
So in my organization, we do a
lot of civic engagement work.
We're a nonprofit organization.
So everything we do in
the civic engagement space
is nonpartisan.
We do nonpartisan
voter registration
as well as get out the vote.
And what we've been
able to do is--
because of the language issues--
develop what we call
the power boost,
a cross-state,
in-language phone banking
system, where we
select, let's say,
five key races in any given
election, or key locations,
and then we'll try to
match the languages that
are available for phone
banking to that population.
And what we found in three
cycles is we've had cases of--
there's this one woman,
Vietnamese woman.
She'd been a citizen
for 20 years.
She voted every year.
But it was the first
time anyone ever
called her to ask her
if she was registered
to vote and to remind
her to get out the vote.
There's an issue of, we need
to get our communities out
to vote.
But we also see that
there's a failure
in the current political
system to really engage
our communities in the vote.
So I think there's
a lot of work to be
done in the whole
civic engagement arena.
BILL IMADA: But we over-index--
Asian-Americans
over-index online.
We are early adopters.
I mean, if you look at Facebook,
Twitter, Instagram, video,
Snapchat, even though WeChat
is significantly better--
bigger-- we over-index by double
to triple digits, 400%, 300%,
600% in terms of early adoption
of the social media platforms.
And that's our bully pulpit.
And the reason why
Asian-Americans and Pacific
Islanders do so well
online is because it
is our way to self express,
and not do it publicly.
Our names are on
there, our handles
are on there, et cetera.
But I do think that we need
to take that activism that we
find online--
I mean, we started the craze
of taking pictures of food.
[LAUGHTER]
But I think that we can now
take it to the next level,
or we can show the
activism in different ways
online to get people
to be involved,
to get people to
register to vote.
And that's where I think
millennials and Gen Z
need to lead the way,
because as Tung said, do not
allow us to dictate
the future for you
or anybody else like
us, including Latinos,
African-Americans, and whites.
You must lead the way
and take over for us.
If you don't, then you're going
to allow people like Lorna,
me Kathy, and Tung to dictate
the future for millennials
and Gen Z. And I don't
want to see that.
So you have the power
of the internet.
That is so powerful in
terms of mobilization
and civic engagement.
You can change the
complexion of this country
and probably the complexion of
other places around the world.
LORNA RANDLETT: I would just
add to what Bill is saying
and put a challenge
out to all of you.
I was talking to a VC
recently, who's Asian, who's
going to raise $100 million.
And it's really to find
new places for Gen Zs
to plug in to help be the
next generations of solutions.
So we've done what we
can to try and seed
the ground with some
runway for you all.
But what we're really
asking is that you
find the language apps
that help get the vote out,
because so many people
are on devices now, right?
Or you find the solution
where you are making us
better in solving that problem.
And so that challenge is one
that we would very gently
like to hand over to you.
And we welcome you
to find those places
where you feel that
you can plug in and get
everyone else to plug in.
The last thing I would say
is just 18 Million Rising.
I don't know if you
guys have heard of that.
But they were able to force some
pretty important corporations
to make some big changes on
behalf of Asian-Americans
in their stances because
they used technology
in a very, very smart way.
So I just encourage you
all and challenge you all
to please pick up the baton
from where we left off.
TUNG NGUYEN: I want to
speak for my generation.
So even though
we're going to rely
on you to do this new thing,
some of us can still do things.
And we should work together.
I think the diversity of
experiences and skills--
I just want to give
an example, which
is after I resigned
from the commission,
we decided to build a
brand new organization
for Vietnamese-American
and progressive causes.
So we call it PIVOT, The
Progressive Vietnamese American
Organization.
It's now only three months
since we decided to do it.
And using social media,
using traditional media,
using email--
that's really old tech,
but using G Suite,
using all kinds
of things, we now
have over 100
members in 12 states.
And we are already
now recognized
as the progressive voice
for Vietnamese-Americans
nationally.
So in three months,
with a guy who
doesn't know what he's doing
on the technological space,
we are able to do that.
So imagine what you could do.
ALLEN LO: So a
number of you talked
about getting out the vote.
And one thing we
are starting to see
is more Asian-American
Pacific Islanders
getting into public
service and elected office.
But still, there's
not that many.
So what do you guys see
as the main barriers
for how we get more AAPIs in
public service and elected
office?
LORNA RANDLETT: I suppose
that one of the things
that at least I'm
working on with my work,
my nonprofit, the Leaders
Forum, is to focus and challenge
this idea that Asians are
not leaders, because I think
that that's completely untrue.
So I think that when you
change the mindset of saying
that every Asian can be a leader
in whatever it is that they
choose, it will come to
pass that they will look
for leadership opportunities.
I think it also matters
the ecosystem that we
build to support those leaders.
So some of the work that I
think that I and everybody
on this panel are doing is
to try to make sure that when
someone decides that
they are going to lead,
that they know that they have
people that have their back.
And that's incredibly important.
So that's what I would say.
BILL IMADA: I have
a funny story,
but I won't tell
the whole story.
But a very, very, very
prominent executive at one
of your competitors who
I got a meeting with,
a 30-minute meeting with,
and it took a long time
to get the meeting-- as
soon as I got to his office,
the first thing out
of his mouth is,
why are Asian people so cheap?
And I said, what?
I mean, this is an executive
of a major company.
And I went, wow, where
did that come from?
And he said, why
do Asian-Americans
hold so tightly to their money?
And I think that's kind
of true in some respects,
is that we have a lot of
very wealthy Asian-Americans
that can give generously
to political causes.
And I'll see them at an
event, and they'll say Bill,
I gave money to the
political cause.
I said, how much did you give?
$50.
And I said, $50.
Wow.
And I said, considering
the Jewish community gives
about $50,000 per person.
And he goes, that's
a lot of money.
So I do think that one of the
things that we're not good at
is--
because we're not as
political in our country.
And I don't want to paint
that broad, broad picture.
But I find that a lot of my
peers in the business community
are not used to giving
more than $100 at a time.
And if we're going
to elect more people,
then we've got to open our
pocketbook a little bit more.
So I think that's
one big reason.
When I see the Jewish-American
community-- again,
don't want to perpetuate
too many stereotypes.
I went to an event,
and they said,
we need to raise $500,000.
And I went, wow, that's
going to be hard to do.
And everybody started
pulling out their checkbooks.
And I said, you guys
are writing checks now?
And they said, Bill,
if we don't do it now,
we're not going
to raise $500,000.
And I went-- it's unbelievable.
Raised $500,000 in
less than 15 minutes.
In our community, a hundred
people will be in the room
and I'll raise $5,000.
So I do think that
we need to be better
about opening our pocketbooks
and supporting campaigns.
ALLEN LO: Right.
Kathy?
KATHY KO CHIN: There are a
lot of bright spots happening
all across the country.
In Congress, we've
moved from 13 members
to 18 members who are
AAPI, Including now three,
count of three Asian-American
women in the Senate,
which is huge, huge,
huge, huge thing.
The other thing that's
a real bright spot
is local and
state-based electeds.
So one person I'm really excited
to meet is Sam Park in Georgia.
So he's a young,
gay, Christian Korean
who has just been elected to
the Georgia State Assembly.
And our organization's--
BILL IMADA: He's fantastic.
KATHY KO CHIN: --trying
to reach out to him--
BILL IMADA: He's fantastic.
KATHY KO CHIN: --and
get to know him.
Just that profile
alone-- it just
sounds really interesting
to get to know him.
There's also a city
council woman in Boston,
a new state legislator
in Illinois.
So a lot of local and
state-based legislators
and electeds.
There is an Asian Pacific
American Institute
for congressional studies.
And they help people
who are thinking
about running for
office learn the ropes
and learn what it takes.
And they have seen
a threefold increase
in interest just
in this last year.
So that's really,
really exciting too.
So I think that this idea
of really cultivating people
to think about being
leaders is really important.
And even if you just
don't decide to run,
but just to learn
more-- thank you--
more about the
political process.
And as Bill says,
to really support
people who are deciding to take
that leadership role is really
important.
TUNG NGUYEN: I want to
second the positivity.
Again, every-- there's a saying.
You shouldn't waste
a good crisis.
This is a crisis in our country.
If you don't do something,
you'll waste it.
In other words, there
are so many people now
who are jazzed up about
the political system.
It's like never before.
All these people who said,
I don't care about politics.
It doesn't make any difference.
All of a sudden they
realize, oh, no, it does--
when it really
changes, it really
makes a huge difference, right?
So I know so many people
who are planning to run
or who are going to run for
office at every single level.
So the story I'm
fond of telling is
there's this woman named
Kathy Tran in Virginia who
had three kids, all under the
age of 10, deliver a baby,
I think, a week
after the election.
And guess what she decided
to do with her life now?
She's running for state
legislature in Virginia.
She says, I have this baby
and I have these four kids.
And I'm thinking
about their future.
And if I sit on the
sideline, their future
could be a lot worse than mine.
And she campaigns with two
kids, a baby on her arm
and a toddler in tow.
I'm very fond of saying--
I said, a lot of
politicians kiss babies.
She brings her own baby.
All right?
So if someone like that can
do that, then if you want to,
you could do it too.
And if someone else out there
wants to, they can do it too.
I'll make a pitch for
the other organization
I've been trying to
start, or have started,
is we need money, right?
So you can't run for office
these days without money.
And we need a way to channel
the money to the candidates
that we support.
So we created a super PAC
called the AAPI Victory
Fund, progressive Asians.
I mean, it's very partisan.
It's very clear.
We're not one
party or the other.
But we support
progressive ideas.
I had some materials back there
in case you're interested.
LORNA RANDLETT: I think that
the other thing that just
want to remind people--
we don't have an AAPI
Supreme Court Justice.
BILL IMADA: Yet.
LORNA RANDLETT: Yet, right?
So there's still
work to do, right?
And so just understand
that those types of things
are going to be really
important for your future
and for your children's
future and whatnot.
So there's definitely
other stuff to be done.
And we all have
different organizations
where we feel that we can have
places for you all to plug in.
KATHY KO CHIN: Absolutely.
LORNA RANDLETT: So I
don't know if there's
any questions for
us, for example, or--
ALLEN LO: So let's do this.
Let's see if there's questions.
We've got a Dory
set up for those
who are on live stream or GVC.
So add your questions there.
Let's start with the room and
see if there's questions here.
And I do want to follow up with
you guys on what you currently
are working on and
share some of that.
So do folks have
questions in the room?
AUDIENCE: Thank you
guys for being her.
It was a very interesting talk.
And you guys mentioned
the generation before
and the millennials, right?
So what is the-- is
there a difference
in views from our
parents' generation
and the older generation
versus the millennials now?
And if there are
differences in views,
what is it that we can do to
help gap that conversation?
LORNA RANDLETT: So my group
has some millennials in it.
There's one woman who's a
27-year-old CEO twice already
in "Fortune's" 30 Under 30.
So she's clearly not
an underachiever.
She didn't have running
water for the first five
years of her life.
But I think that the
important difference
in terms of your question
is the following.
I think that people
like her are more bold.
And I think that they're
more willing to engage.
I think that they have--
a lot of them have more
resources or more ambition
to be able to play in
places and in politics,
like Bill is speaking about.
I think that in terms
of bridging the gap,
it's just about communication.
I think it's like
what Bill's saying.
It's about telling stories.
It's about telling
people that there are--
even if you do a little
bit, the question is,
if not you, who else?
Right?
So if your parents don't vote,
then that's one less vote.
And there are places
where races were decided
because hundreds--
a few hundred people
didn't cast their
ballots, right?
So getting your parents to vote,
other people in community, also
millennials to engage
and not be apathetic.
I mean, I heard some millennials
sat out of the election
because they were just
like, well, why bother?
Whatever it is, it's not really
the answer we're looking for.
So that's what I would say.
BILL IMADA: I think
what we're finding
is that the millennial
generation is
saying that they don't
know what they don't know.
I don't know if you guys
have ever heard of Boba Guys.
But Andrew Chau, who is
a leader in the city,
actually wanted to
tag along with us
when we went to Washington.
And he brought a group of
millennial entrepreneurs
from all around the
country with him.
And we went to a
lot of meetings.
And he said, wow,
I need to know how
our political process works.
And I have to be honest.
I don't know how it works.
And you guys are teaching
us what we need to know,
because everything is connected.
And so I do think that
everybody's so caught up
right now in running
their businesses
or moving up the
corporate ladder
or doing a good job
at their companies
or maybe working on
one specific project
that they can actually
do something that'll
change their communities.
They're not focused necessarily
on the bigger picture.
So I think what
we've been able to do
is bring those people
together and say everything
is related and connected.
Whatever you do can
impact multiple areas.
So I think that one of the
things that we're finding
is people don't know
what they don't know.
And pointing these things
out and showing them
how one simple act can change
everything about government,
a community, about a corporation
was very important and very
eye-opening for me personally.
TUNG NGUYEN: My
understanding is that--
I think a lot of millennials
don't identify themselves
in one group or another.
And I think that's
sometimes a problem for them
to figure out what they do.
For example, tech-- a lot
of people who are tech maybe
have not have been interested
in politics before.
But now, with the
current environment,
there is a movement
for tech to be involved
in political action,
and particularly
for Asian-American
tech to be involved.
So you could engage
in that space,
or you can engage in the women's
rights space, where again,
a lot of issues are going
on that are addressing that.
The thing that we
encourage AAPIs to do,
though, is whichever
space you engage in, also
make sure you engage
as an AAPI person
as well, for two reasons.
One is, those viewpoints need
to be heard in those spaces,
because they may be different.
And the other is to be
able to bring all that back
to your community and see
how you can also leverage
the strength that you
have in those movements
to help your own community and
your parents and your family.
ALLEN LO: Any other questions?
Anything on the Dory?
Nope?
KATHY KO CHIN: I'll
answer your question.
ALLEN LO: All right.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thank you so much
for being here.
My name's Brendan Chan.
And I'm really glad
to, first of all,
be a proud member of the
Asian Googlers Network.
I'm actually also
pretty involved
in the Hispanic
Googlers Network,
and the two networks have
worked together quite a bit
on issues related to
both of our communities
like immigration,
like you talked about.
One thing I think that
we have both found,
however, is that
there's a perception,
right, that some of these
issues are only issues applied
to particular communities.
Immigration in
particular sometimes
is seen as just, right, a
particular issue that affects
the Hispanic Latino community.
And so I'd be
interested in, when
you talk about showing up,
when you talk about finding
the right issues, how do you
also band together so that we
realize that any progress
for any racial justice issue
is actually progress for
all of our communities,
and any advice that you
might have for us who
are doing some of
that work or trying
to continue being involved?
KATHY KO CHIN: Thank you.
That's a great question.
So first of all, my kids
are Asian and Hispanic.
So I really appreciate that.
The other thing is,
between now and 2040,
being multiracial will be
the single largest segment
within the AAPI community.
So it is this idea
that, for AAPIs, we
already have to be really
inclusive because it's
50 different countries and
all these different languages,
but even more so because
of how multiracial
our community is
becoming and is already,
but also will
continue to become.
At the Health Forum, the Asian
Pacific Islander American
Health Forum where I
work, we are really
privileged to sit
at the same table
with 11 other
organizations who are all
considered racial equity anchors
by the Kellogg Foundation.
That's the NAACP, the
National Urban League,
the National Council of La
Raza, the National Congress
of American Indians, and
other organizations as well.
So for us, it is
working in coalition,
working in partnership,
being really
strong allies with each other
is really, really critical.
And what we have done
is we've actually
discussed different issues,
whether it be voting rights
or immigration, and
try to figure out
what is the commonality and
how can we speak out together.
So for example, on the
10th anniversary of 9/11,
we came together
and wrote a prayer,
a non-denominational prayer, but
about peace and about working
together.
And fortunately, the
Kellogg Foundation
was able to take a full page
ad in the New York Times
magazine--
New York Times
newspaper for that.
We've also responded
to the massacres in--
where was that?
In Wisconsin, with
the South-Asians,
as well as with Ferguson.
So all of those intersectional
and cross-racial work
is really, really important.
Because as you said,
things like immigration
don't just affect Latinos.
It also affects our communities
in a really significant way.
The school-to-prison
pipeline-- I think people
have heard about that.
Well, in the Southeast
Asian community,
it's a
school-to-prison-to-deportation
pipeline.
And we also see that in
the Hispanic community.
For any given issue that
our nation is facing,
there is a specific
slice for AAPIs.
But we also have to realize
that to find the right solutions
and to have the right
advocacy solutions,
we have to do it in
coalition with each other.
Absolutely.
BILL IMADA: I totally agree with
the intersectionality comment,
Brendan.
I mean, we have
something in common
with every single
Googler group here.
The LGBT community also
faces immigration challenges,
separation of families.
If you immigrate
here, you have to go
through a different process
if you're gay or lesbian.
African-Americans-- some of
the fastest growing communities
in our country are
black communities,
coming from not only the
Caribbean, but from Africa.
So I do think that there's
a lot of intersectionality.
And it's important for
all of us to find that.
And that's what
we're doing, I think,
at the Asian-American community.
The Japanese can be reaching
out to the Muslim community,
because we were interned.
And there was racial profiling
around the Chinese Exclusion
Act, as there was for Japanese
being interned in World War II.
So the Japanese
community reached out
to the Muslim
community, said, we
know what it's like to
be pigeonholed and pegged
as outsiders.
So we're going to help you.
So I do think that if we
find those intersections,
it's going to be a lot
easier to focus on the things
that make us unique
and different later.
ALLEN LO: Maybe as
a final question
here, just given time, each of
you can just talk about just,
what are you focused
on right now?
What's your main priority,
in a minute or less?
LORNA RANDLETT: Sure.
OK, minute or less.
All right.
So I started a
nonprofit, actually,
as an inspiration for
what Bill talked about,
which is how many executives
that we're losing, because I
think that it's a
shame when you get
those leaders to
the top and they've
worked their entire lives.
Their ability to be able
to help other people up
is obviously not there anymore
if they're not there anymore.
So we are leadersforum--
all one word--
dot org.
And I focus on making sure
that we protect those leaders,
that we develop them, that
we give them an education
about what public service is.
And I would just say in
closing, to add to your point,
just make sure that you're
forming bonds with leaders that
are of other races, because
you can get a lot done, right,
when you're in those
leadership positions.
And it's those
relationships that
actually make a difference.
Having a Rooney Rule
like they have in the NFL
for all executives
and making sure
that they interview
someone of every ethnic--
every ethnic group
in the top C-suite
would be something that would be
really beneficial to all of us
in America.
BILL IMADA: Google has been
very supportive of me on this.
So I started the National
Millennial Community,
and now we're starting
the Gen Z Council.
And that group has gone from
six universities to over 30.
And we're now expanding
overseas as well.
And that group is to
create conversation.
So it includes Republicans that
voted for Trump to progressives
that voted for Bernie to
people that didn't vote at all.
And it's all about sitting
down and having conversations
that make us unique.
And so the proudest
moment in the group
was when a Muslim
woman from Denver
who said she voted for Bernie
got into a huge argument
with a woman from eastern
Oregon who voted for Trump.
And they argued in the bus
for 20 minutes straight.
And then afterwards, they said--
the woman from
the vote for Trump
said, I've never
met a Muslim before.
And she said, well,
I'm that person.
And then the woman
that was Muslim
said, I never met
a person that was
from a town of 50
people in the country.
And the two of them sat
together and had a conversation.
And they are now best friends.
So my movement is to
have civil discourse
to try to find out how we can
find ways to work together.
KATHY KO CHIN: At the Health
Forum, for the last eight
years, we've been working
on the Affordable Care Act.
And there's a handout, too.
This is a map of where
we've worked in 23 states
to help a million people enroll
in the Affordable Care Act
health insurance expansions.
And we did it in 56 languages.
So as you can imagine, then,
defending the Affordable Care
Act has been a big fight
for us since January 3,
when Congress went
back into session.
If it's something
that you care about,
this is an opportunity
for you to engage.
I'm not telling you what to
say to your member of Congress.
But I can also send you a
link with a phone number
that will connect you to
your member of Congress,
and you can let
them know how you
feel about health insurance.
Just yesterday, the
Congressional Budget Office
did release the
analysis that said
the current bill in Congress
will see 23 million people lose
their health insurance coverage.
And of those, 2 million will
be Asian-Americans and Native
Hawaiians and Pacific Islanders.
So it is a really
critical issue,
even if it doesn't
affect us individually,
especially if you
have health insurance
through your employer.
But it really does
affect millions
of people across the country.
Thanks.
TUNG NGUYEN: So in my
day job, I do research
on Asian-American health.
So I'll continue to do that,
which is really generating
data and interventions
to improve
the health of our communities.
But I've decided, not
too long ago, that--
I have to take the
gloves off, and I
want to be completely partisan.
I do not feel,
actually, that I can
work in the space where
I'm nonpartisan when
the political situation is
such that it oppresses me,
my community, and all
the people I care about.
And so I've already mentioned
the 501(c)(4) that we started
with PIVOT, called Progressive
Vietnamese American
Organization.
So if you're Vietnamese
or fellow travelers,
talk to me about that.
And we also are very engaged
in super political activity
through the super PAC
with AAPI Victory Fund.
So again, we're trying to
identify progressive candidates
and support them.
ALLEN LO: Thanks to AGN
for arranging this panel,
in particular to Tiffany
[? Su ?] and to Maggie
[? Huang. ?]
[APPLAUSE]
But a big thank you
to the panelists
for spending the time,
for sharing their views,
and for helping to
inspire us here at Google.
So thank you very
much for coming.
LORNA RANDLETT: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]